so I'd now like to bring up Lauren
Kessler who will be introducing Thomas
Hager
director of literary nonfiction here at
the University of Oregon
Lauren Kessler is the author of 11 books
including the best-selling clever girl
Elizabeth Bentley the spy who assured in
the McCarthy era aging well which she
co-authored with Tom Hager and the
upcoming Dancing with Rose life among
the demented and deranged due out in
June 2007 Kessler also teaches writing
seminars and is the founder and editor
of étude an online magazine devoted to
new and emerging voices and literary
nonfiction please help me welcome Lauren
Kessler
thank you a long time ago I read a story
that Tom wrote it was one of his first
efforts as a science writer he had
gotten a bachelor's degree in biology
from Portland State and master's degree
in microbiology from Oregon Health
Sciences University and was just a
dissertation away from a PhD in
immunology at UC Davis when he had this
aha moment he'd rather be writing about
science than doing it he'd rather be out
in the world exploring stories than in
the lab Oscar izing chick embryos so he
went back to school here at the
University of Oregon in the School of
Journalism and he studied writing that
story that I read it was a profile of a
researcher here at the University began
with a terrific lead and the lead was
he's high on the scientists favorite
drug discovery Tom wrote that about
somebody else but as equally and even
more true about himself tom has an
endless boundless curiosity about things
the rest of us know nothing about or
never even thought we'd be interested in
from blood diseases to bird guano from
the history of dye manufacturing to the
politics of the Pasteur Institute we
don't know how fascinating these things
are and we never would have imagined
they would be fascinating at all until
Tom writes about them and we read his
work his more than 100 magazine articles
in publications ranging from the Journal
of the American Medical Association to
Reader's Digest and his books he loves
to do research he loves to discover what
happened and why and he has a talent for
making the most complicated ideas
medical concepts scientific theories so
understandable that he makes you feel
smart when you read his work people
don't like science tom says they are
intimidated by it but not if they read
his
stuff tom is the author of three books
including two biographies of linus
pauling one of the 20th century's most
important scientists he's also the
co-author of another book on Aging and
the co-editor of still another book so
that makes five if you're counting
tonight he'll be talking about in
reading from his new book demon under
the microscope which is a meticulously
researched compellingly written story of
the discovery of the world's first
miracle drug this is a grand story and
mr. Hager tells it well The Wall Street
Journal said book page called it says
that it grips the reader from the first
paragraph a story of dedication luck
tragedy and triumph that's still
relevant today and Publishers Weekly
says it is a testimony
it is a testament rather to Haggar skill
that the inherently unsexy process of
finding chemicals is as exciting as an
account of the hunt for a Russian
submarine tom has been the founding
editor of a trade magazine for chemists
the editor of Oregon quarterly the
director of communications for the
University of Oregon and most recently
the resuscitator tireless cheerleader
and director of the University of Oregon
Press we should all be glad that he's
decided to give up his day job and write
full-time because that means more of his
work to read I'm delighted to present to
you this evening one of my favorite
writers and most definitely my favorite
husband Tom Hager
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
tonight and talk about the demon under
the microscope which is a book that I
started about two years ago quite by
accident when I ran across information
in an encyclopedia that led me to
another bit of information in another
encyclopedia that led me to another bit
of information that ended up teaching me
about a fellow I'd never heard of before
named Gerhard amok this book is in part
a biography of Gerhard democ Nobel Prize
winner in 1939 and a man who more than
any other single person created a
revolution in medicine a revolution that
we're all benefiting from today it's
hard to remember it now because we live
in an age of medical miracles it's
difficult to remember what it was like
not very long ago before that Age
started and I think you can I think you
can put a starting point on that time
when the revolution began the revolution
that we are all benefiting from now and
that time was the day before Christmas
1932 that is exactly when the first shot
was fired in the revolution and we're
all still feeling the effects of it now
I'm gonna tell you the story of that day
in just a little bit but first I want to
talk about what life was like before
that point I don't know how many of you
have taken science classes I imagine
that quite a few people have and when
you're in a science class sometimes the
professor in front of the class will do
a little experiment where they have kind
of a flask of clear liquid you know and
they'll drip something into it drip drip
drip drip drip and that's some other
clear liquid drip drip drip and swirl it
around and at some point all the liquid
in the flask will turn a color it'll
turn purple or red or green whatever
because the the chemical equilibrium has
reached a certain point and magic
happens suddenly the whole thing changes
this day in 1932 was like that
everything changed on that day before
that point medicine was very different
Voltaire wrote that the art of Medicine
consists of amusing the patient while
nature cures the disease and that was
very true he wrote that in the 18th
century and that was the art of medicine
because medical people couldn't really
do much else in the 18th century if you
got a disease if you gotta say a
communicable disease an infectious
disease like the kind of diseases that
are caused by bacteria or viruses once
the disease started in your body there
was nothing anybody could do to cure you
there was no medicine you could take
that would cure you and the situation
didn't change over the next hundred and
fifty years that you know people were
used to it that was the way things had
always been from the beginning of time
from the beginning of history once you
got an infectious disease a doctor or
whatever kind of health care provider
was involved could give you palliative
care that is they could give you
medicines to ease your symptoms
medicines to make the pain go away or to
lower the fever maybe to make you more
comfortable they could talk to you they
could ease your way through the disease
but what they couldn't do was cure it
150 years later you would think that
modern medicine would have taken hold
but in the 1930s Lewis Thomas Road and
Lewis Lewis Thomas was a famous American
physician who wrote a book called the
lives of a cell that I hope many of you
have read lives of a cell is a great
book of essays in 1930 in the early
1930s Thomas was a student medical
student and he wrote of that time
whether you survived or not and again
this is in the 1930s depended on the
natural history of the disease itself
medicine made little or no difference
that was what life was like prior to 75
years ago I'm gonna tell you a story a
last story to illustrate the point
that was in the summer of 1924 a skinny
gawky teenage boy loped across the South
Lawn of the White House in the summer of
1924 with a tennis racket in his hand he
looked frail but when he played tennis
he gave it everything he had on this
particular afternoon he wished he'd worn
socks under his sneakers because when he
got back to his room after playing he
found a blister on his big toe which he
treated with iodine and for God two days
later Calvin Coolidge jr. the son of the
President of the United States started
to feel weak and feverish he felt pain
in his legs and went to bed when the
White House physician Admiral Joelle
Boone examined the boy
Admiral Joe a boon by the way is a
direct descendent of Daniel Boone the
famous Daniel Boone the Admiral found
the foot with the blister inflamed and
tender the physician cleaned the foot
bandaged it and ordered a regimen of bed
rest and regular changes of antiseptic
dressings when President Coolidge heard
that his son was ill he became unusually
concerned because Calvin jr. was his
favorite child his youngest some
historians later pointed out that the
boys face seemed to resemble the
president's dead mother who he had loved
very much but who had died very young in
any case the boy and the president were
very close Boone told the president and
the first lady not to be too concerned
the foot was infected but with proper
care healthy young men could shake off
an infection like that within a week or
two he would keep a close eye on Calvin
jr. the next day the boys stiffness and
pain were worse Boone was a decisive
physician he had won a medal of honor in
France during World War one and he was
not one to spend much time playing wait
and see he drew blood samples and drove
them personally to Walter Reed Hospital
when he saw the results his concern
increased it looked as if the boy's
blood was infected with a particularly
bad germ a fast grower that was famous
for spreading quickly through the body
shedding poisons as it went it looked
like streptococcus pyogenes the main
culprit in wound infections during World
War one
Boone started moving quickly when he got
back to the White House he found Calvin
Jr's temperature soaring
he did what he could ease the pain
cleaned the area changed the dressings
and hope the boys immune response would
kick in soon
the next night he again consulted with
the President and First Lady and the day
after that July 4th the president's
birthday the boy was worse
the planned festivities were toned down
guests guests were asked to leave the
White House the boy's room was turned
into a hospital ward every medical
expert on blood infections on the East
Coast was called in the physicians tried
everything they could to stop the
infection which was now moving up the
boy's leg on July 5th news of Calvin
Junior's condition hit the newspapers
even the Republican president's
political opponents rallied behind him
attendees at the Democratic National
Convention which was going on at the
same time in New York City received
regular bulletins on Calvin Junior's
health and sent sympathies to the White
House phone calls and telegrams of
support more than 10,000 of them began
flooding in the president seemed stunned
unable to do his work he stopped what he
was doing a dozen times a day and made
his way to the boys room the journalist
William Ellen White told the story of
the president finding a rabbit in the
White House garden
coaxing the rabbit close enough to catch
and then trotting it up to his son's
room
he got a weak smile in return a Coolidge
family friend told the journalist that
the president would have carried that
boy the whole of the White House grounds
a handful at a time if it would have
done any good blood transfusions were
sometimes tried in cases like this
although they were risky blood typing
technology was crude at the time and the
patient's own immune system could react
against the transfusion the next day
July 6th White House staffers began
offering their blood but by then Boone
had decided to get the boy out of the
White House Calvin jr. was taken in an
ambulance to Walter Reed Hospital with a
pail first lady following in a car
behind and there seven of the world's
best physicians went to work giving the
boy injections blood transfusions
artificial respiration a last ditch
operation the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court wrote his wife the whole
country is at the deathbed of young
Calvin Coolidge and he then told her
that he had talked with a physician who
told him that it had been hopeless from
the beginning
once a strep pyogenes infection hit the
bloodstream it was as bad as being
bitten by a poisonous snake he wrote the
president in the first lady stayed at
the hospital through the night while
their son passed in and out of delirium
toward the end he thought he was leading
troops into battle and they were winning
a positive sign the president thought
but then Calvin juniors body went limp
and he murmured we surrender dr. Boone
said forcefully no Calvin never
surrender but the boy slipped into a
coma on July 7th five days after Boone
first looked at a blister on the boy's
toe the president's son died Calvin
Coolidge fell into a deep depression
that some historians believe marked his
entire second term turning the once
energetic politician into the man
everyone after that called silent Cal so
that was the state of Medicine in 1924
not very long ago within living memory
for millions of people and that boy was
the most privileged young man in the
world perhaps he had access to the best
medical care in the world and he died
from an infected blister this book is
what is about what happened to change
that and it's difficult I think to
realize when you're a baby boomer like
me for instance that we were the first
generation in human history to grow up
in an age of antibiotics in an age when
a physician could actually do something
to stop diseases for us when we were
growing up when I was growing up many
when everyone in this room I think was
growing up if you got an ear infection
is a little kid for instance you nn2 the
doctor and the doctor gave you a
prescription for antibiotics and your
ear got better your parents our
grandparents prior to 1932 when they
went in with an ear infection they got
something to bring the fever down and
the best wishes of the physician and
then the natural course of the disease
would play its itself out and they would
get better or they wouldn't if it
progressed to something more serious
they got more sympathy and perhaps some
painkillers when it got more serious for
us if we were taken into the doctor we
got more out of the
until it went away and we got used to
that I was used to it that's life for so
many of us but it's not a kind of life
that anyone in history had and tell us
after after Calvin jr. died after Calvin
Coolidge jr. died people began looking
for medicines that would stop these
infections it wasn't just because of
Calvin Coolidge jr. people had been
looking ever since the ancient Egyptians
at least and maybe before for something
that could stop disease in the body they
were looking for magic medicines that
could heal the sick raise the dead bring
people back from the grave but after
centuries and centuries of looking
nothing really had ever been found
and by around 1915 or 1920 physicians
got tired of looking this was an age of
chemistry you know the early part of the
20th century there's a lot of good
chemistry going on there are a lot of
medicines that were out there and a lot
of claims being made about medicines
that were made out of chemicals none of
them worked
so when physicians heard claim after
claim and nothing healed their patients
they got tired of hearing the claims and
the operative mood among physicians in
the early part of the 20th century was
one that was summarized by a historian
as therapeutic nihilism therapeutic
nihilism what that means basically is
that nothing did any good
so you might as well just take good care
of your patient support them sort of as
as human beings support human beings
with nursing care and by alleviating
their concerns by talking to them by
telling them what might happen in the
course of the disease by holding their
hands that was the old image of the
family physician you know that you sort
of see in literature of the day you know
the guy in the horse and buggy who would
go around do do house calls and be
kindly and kind of poor yeah that was
physician back then but because of this
attitude of therapeutic nihilism a lot
of people who might have been looking
for medicines just gave up looking for
medicines because after so long of the
the attitude was nothing's going to work
except for one research team there was
really only one place in the world where
a lot of research continued to go on in
this search for medicines that could
stop infections that was in Germany in
Germany had the best chemists in the
world Germany before and after World War
one was the Center for Science in the
world they had enormous industries kind
of the first high-tech industries of the
day that were built on manipulating
chemicals they were made their money
really off of dyes Lauren mentioned dye
manufacturing the German big chemical
companies like bear and her extend and
egg VII and so forth hadn't started
making artificial dyes for coloring
silks and wool and clothing there was an
enormous worldwide demand for that they
made tons of money and they figured out
how to manipulate molecules to make
these dyes they hired a lot of chemists
to make them they were really amazing
industries for the day well after the
dye market started to dry up and get
competitive some of them started looking
for ways to use those same techniques to
make medicine okay so at the Bayer
company you've heard of Bayer Aspirin
everybody's heard of Bayer Aspirin the
Bayer company was a company in Germany
that invented or discovered or sort of
stumbled across bare Hass pirin while
they were doing research and found out
that it was very profitable this was an
artificial chemical that basically they
still don't know how it works and they
keep finding new stuff that it works for
the the medicine made them so much money
that they decided to start a whole
research program in the 1920s to find
more medicines and and they hired a
young physician in 1927 to head up this
research program because the guy who had
been heading it up died when he nicked
his he nicked his neck with a razor and
he died of a blood infection and so they
hired they hired a young physician to
take his place and this fellow's name
was Gary
don't mock don't mock the hero of the
story was a boy who had grown up to
manhood during World War one he as a
teenager he went in the German army and
he was wounded and he was after he
recovered he was sent to work in a field
hospital for the German army in Russia
where for two years he tended horribly
wounded men World War one was was truly
horrific conflict you know you can't
imagine the kinds of wounds that people
saw in warfare in those days because
World War one was really the first war
where people had a lot of high
explosives to play with and they had
enormous howitzers and in aerial bombs
hand grenades tanks and they were
blowing soldiers just to smithereens
so these wounded men would come into
this field hospital out in the woods of
the Ukraine where Gerhardt democ about
18 or 20 years old
soft soft physicians surgeons sew them
back together seemingly successfully
they had excellent surgeons surgery was
very highly developed art even man and
they had wonderful surgeons who took
these men and and really piece them back
together beautifully and then often a
week later after the surgery as the men
were recovering a wound infection would
set in everything would look great and
then suddenly the wound would turn a
different color the men would grow weak
their temperatures would soar and a few
days after that they would be dead
because a bacteria had gotten in the
wound caused an infection and killed
them more people more soldiers died in
World War one from wound infections than
from the wounds themselves democ saw
hundreds of soldiers die that way and he
swore at the end of the war as a young
man that he was going to dedicate his
life to as he put it stopping this
madness so he went to medical school
after the war got his medical degree and
then was hired by the Bayer company to
head up this research program to find a
medicine that
would do exactly what he wanted to be
doing with his life
stopping infections once they started in
the body even though nobody really
thought they could do it Baer was
willing to gamble and they had money
enough to do it
so democ was set up with a research
program in 1927 and for four years he
tested almost every chemical that bear
had in its wide arsenal of chemicals
this is a chemical company they made new
chemicals every day and every day doma
could test them to see if they could
stop infections in mice that was his
that was his test system was mice and
for four years he tested hundreds and
hundreds of chemicals and nothing worked
he had zero success rate until that day
toward Christmas of 1932 when a new
chemical came in it was a dye it was a
dye like chemical it was it was red and
it came in solid form as tablets and the
end the system was this he'd he'd have a
cage full of mice and what he did be to
shoot all might say 24 mice he'd shoot
him all up with bacteria with the strep
that was that was the main culprit and
wound infections streptococcus was the
name of the bacteria that caused these
wound infections and that's what he was
testing he would shoot them up with
enough strep to kill each Mouse say a
hundred times over a real overdose of
deadly of deadly bacteria so that there
was no doubt that those mice were going
to die and then he'd take the group
split it in half and he would give half
the mice whatever the test medicine was
and half the mice would get nothing okay
what had happened hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of times in his tests was
that all the mice would die and that was
that was a negative test and in this
time however as they were nearing
Christmas in 1932 they gave the test
group of mice this red medicine it was
the seven hundred and thirtieth chemical
that they had tested
and they came back a few days later
actually domak was on vacation his lab
assist and one of his lab assistants a
young woman came in and she saw the test
screw all the all the mice who had
received no medicine were dead as
expected but the test group of mice were
all as she put it later jumping up and
down
very lively it was nobody in bear had
ever seen anything like it and no one in
the world had ever seen anything like it
everybody thought it was a mistake
because it was too good to be true all
the tests mice were alive and on all the
control mice who didn't receive the
medicine were dead all dead all alive
and it was really it was really beyond
belief so doumitt came back from
vacation saw these results and started
running new tests over and over and over
again and every new test showed the same
thing sometimes there'd be one or two
mice in the test group because they were
look they started lowering the dose of
medicine to try and find out you know
what the dosage levels were like and
eventually they got to a point where
some some of those mice who got the
medicine would die but it was amazing
this thing stopped deadly bacterial
infections in mice you know in a way
that was almost like magic on Christmas
Day 1932 the bear company filed a patent
for this dye it was within days of these
test results they went in then somehow
they got the Patent Office to open up on
Christmas they filed they filed a patent
application on Christmas and because
they thought they had the world's
greatest medicine they thought that they
had something that was going to make
them so much money around the world
because it was the only thing available
to fight infections it was a huge
discovery and they knew it so they filed
their patent application with dreams of
riches floating from their heads
uh-hum so then they said they're seen
ships to Paris where where there's a
group of French guys French researchers
at an institute in Paris who are always
jealous of the Germans the Germans have
all the money the Germans have all the
great chemists the Germans have these
huge chemical outfits you know that are
doing this wonderful research and the
French are working these shabby
little rooms in in in the at this
particular group in the past year
Institute which was housed in an old
villa sort of in an unfashionable
district of Paris
but what they what the French really
enjoyed doing was reading German patents
and figuring out how to make whatever
the Germans were making and and then
finding a way to market it in France for
themselves and they were good at it this
group this group in the past year
Institute was pretty funny they were in
London really a wonderful group so much
different than the Germans you know the
Germans were all men they were all you
know they worked extremely hard all the
time it was very very sort of
straightforward hierarchical research
medicine in this French group in the
Pasteur Institute had men and women
working together some of them were
married there were romances once there
was a duel and and and they just they'd
loved what they did though and they were
really they really thought that they
were doing good for the world
by breaking German patents and bringing
German medicines more cheaply to the
world in any case they got a hold of the
patent for this drug this new medicine
and they started picking it apart and
and within a very short time they found
out how to make it and they made it and
then they found out something very very
interesting and they found this out by
accident what they found out was that
the molecule the Germans had made came
in two parts one part was the dye
molecule the red dye that was very that
was very complicated molecule extremely
complex molecule and absolutely new
totally patentable but then what
happened in in the they discovered was
that chemically you could break off a
little side chain that the Germans had
added onto this complex molecule the
little side chain had sulphur in it
this very small molecule and and it was
used in the dye industry to make dyes
stick more tightly to fabrics and the
Germans had obviously put it on there in
order to make the dye stick more tightly
to bacteria which was sort of the idea
of these medicines the dye based
medicines were supposed to stick to
bacteria and kill them well they'd put
on this little sulfur sidechain to help
their dye do that and it seemed to work
but what the French found
because in a certain test they have four
extra mice around they didn't know what
to test against these four mice so they
took the little side chain and they
tested that in their mice it was an
absolute fluke the guy who did this
later when the Nobel Prize himself and
he wrote about it and he and he said
that it was it was an incredible
accident that they happened to have four
extra mice on that day and they happen
to have a little of this side chain
available and he tested it against strep
in these mice and he found out that it
cured that essentially the die was
nothing the die was inactive what was
doing all of the good for the mice was
this little side chain and it was called
sulfanilamide that was the name of the
side chain well the French couldn't
believe that either and they retested
and retested and retested because
obviously the germans had pinned their
hopes on the dye molecule because as it
turned out the little side chain was
unpatentable it was a cheap industrial
chemical that had been sitting in cans
on everybody's shelf for decades and had
been out of patent 44 years anybody
could make it and it was cheap to make
it was a very simple molecule but that's
what the medicine was it was not a dye
it was white and as the this fellow who
made the discovery daniel Beauvais the
Nobel Prize winner in France later said
it was a great surprise that the red
German sports car had a little white
engine and and he and he used that fact
to embarrass the Germans when the German
when the Germans heard that the French
published their results and they
published it within a very short time of
the Germans patenting patenting their
their medicine
when the Germans heard about the French
results the word in the German labs was
that the news struck like a bombshell
they couldn't believe it because not
only did it mean that that they were
searching for the wrong thing they'd
been searching for dyes for years not
only were they searching for the wrong
thing but they weren't going to make any
money off their medicine because anybody
could make it now they started doing the
logical thing which was they started
pointing fingers at each other with
within the laboratory in German Doh mock
on one side the chemists who'd made this
die on the other side each of them
saying why didn't you figure that one
out before we went out with this drug
but as it turned out there was nothing
they could do about it
the French started making sulfa and the
English started testing sulfa and it
became very clear that the medicine was
just as good as everyone in germany had
said it cured humans of diseases that no
one had ever cured before with a
chemical it cured them so effectively
that some of these diseases which were
common before 19 the mid 1930s you
actually don't hear about anymore very
much one of them is called erysipelas
erysipelas as it is a strep infection of
the skin that caused sort of flashes of
epidemics since the Middle Ages and
killed tens of thousands of people era
syphilis was stopped there was a disease
called child bed fever you know you read
about women dying after they give
childbirth often in say the 19th century
we read books or see plays about how
dangerous childbirth was well the reason
childbirth was dangerous before the
1930s was that the process of childbirth
opens up a wound in the uterus where the
placenta detaches and that's a route for
infection and sometimes new mothers
would become in fact it would get a
blood infection that that killed them
and what the English found for instance
was that sulfa stopped child bed fever
just miraculously and soon they were
trying sulfa on all kinds of diseases
this was all happening in Europe and it
was happening in a way where it was just
as the news was breaking very few people
in the United States would have heard of
it because most of the stuff that was
going on was in Germany and in German
journals and stuff in the United States
had it hadn't quite filtered over to the
US until 1936 when another president's
son fell ill and this was 12 years after
Calvin Coolidge jr. and I'm gonna read
you a little bit from the book about
what happened this time around
I should preface it by saying that
Calla that FDR jr. was a sort of tabloid
fodder at the day Franklin Delano
Roosevelt his father was president for
four terms and he was a fixture in the
American political scene he was a
left-wing very Liberal Democrat and
Calvin Calvin Coolidge FDR jr. his son
was this handsome kind of big strapping
hunk of a guy who was a Harvard crew
member and he fell in love FDR jr. fell
in love with a woman called Eleanor
DuPont who was an heiress and she was an
heiress to a fortune that had been made
by a gunpowder manufacturing company the
DuPont company the DuPont's were
staunchly right-wing Republican so they
decided to keep the romance secret and
for months they were seeing each other
in kind of this Romeo and Juliet way and
and they were being tracked by reporters
and it was really it had it happened now
you would have seen it all over the
National Enquirer but at the time they
just wanted to keep things very quiet
well FDR jr. was going to parties with
Eleanor Roosevelt army with with Eleanor
DuPont and and and he fell ill one night
he started to feel like he had a cold
and his sinuses got infected and pretty
soon he felt so bad that he was checked
into the Massachusetts General Hospital
and at Mass General they put him to bed
and they gave him what care they could
they didn't know anything about sulfa
and his infection started to get worse
it turned out he had a strep throat and
strep throat now doesn't seem like much
everybody gets strep throat but back in
those days if you got strep throat it
could be a death sentence because strep
could eat through tissues it could get
through your throat into your
bloodstream once strep got in your
bloodstream there's a good chance you'd
die FDR jr.
kept getting sicker and sicker the
physicians at Mass General kept saying
oh he's going to be fine don't worry
they would tell for instance Eleanor
Roosevelt the boy's mother don't worry
he's going to be fine he'll be released
in a few days and a few days would go by
he got worse and worse and finally after
he was in the hospital for three weeks
Eleanor Roosevelt took charge she
consulted her friends in the Boston area
because he was in Mass General and
arranged to bring the best ear nose and
throat man in the Northeast dr. George
Loring Toby jr. Ian as her son's
personal physician
Toby was 55 years old and at the peak of
his skills he was of the wrong political
persuasion a staunch Republican
like the DuPont's with a love of
expensive suits a blueblood who could
trace his lineage well back before the
American Revolution but he was also a
fine physician a quote fashionable and
crackerjack Boston ear nose and throat
specialist as Time magazine put it he
was well trained well respected
well-connected and highly recommended
after examining the president's son Toby
ordered immediate changes in his care he
was concerned about a tender spot
forming under FDR Jr's right cheek Toby
thought it was likely to be a pocket of
infection a small but growing abscess
perhaps an important part of the reason
the young man was not getting better he
suspected strep because of the throat
but ordered lab tests to see exactly
what sort of organism was causing the
problem and then he asked the first
lady's permission to perform an
operation to drain it suddenly things
began to go seriously wrong before Toby
could operate
FDR Jr's throat began to close making it
difficult to breathe his fever spiked to
a more dangerous level he began coughing
up blood it appeared that he was
hemorrhaging from the throat Toby made
some fast decisions the lab tests when
they came back showed that FDR juniors
abscess and throat infection were caused
as he had suspected by strep this
worried toby deeply the strep had gotten
into FDR juniors sinuses the bleeding in
the throat could mean the strep was
destroying the tissue there possibly
opening a passageway to an infection of
the bloodstream
a blood infection with this particular
germ would make everything up to this
point look mild the wild card was the
bacterium itself strep was very bad as
Toby well knew the cause of millions of
deaths some strains of strep were
however were far worse than others there
are factors in our favor he told mrs.
Roosevelt years
as strong young physically fit and the
staff here is giving him the best
possible care
he then advised mrs. Roosevelt to return
to her son's bedside as quickly as
possible in addition to his other
attributes toby read the medical
literature voraciously keeping up with
all the latest developments
unlike many physicians he was not afraid
to try something new he had heard about
the German drug and had been among the
first in the United States to try it on
a few in fact on a few patients with
severe infections and has seen good
results it was still unproven still
experimental and it went against his
grain to try an experimental drug on the
president's son but he was running out
of options he and mrs. Roosevelt talked
about it before she would approve its
youth she wanted to hear more she called
other experts asked about side effects
and hesitated about using her son as she
wrote a guinea pig but after hearing
that side effects seemed to be mild she
gave Toby permission to try it in
mid-december during FDR juniors third
week in the hospital Toby administered
the first injections dosage was still a
question mark given the patient's
deteriorating condition Toby erred on
the side of aggressive therapy and
dispensed two generous doses injecting
the red liquid and managing to get some
pills down his patients damaged throat
there was little change in the first
hours reporters now knew there was a
story and they asked began asking Toby
questions on December 13th he told them
that he was waiting for FDR juniors
fever to lower it was still too high to
allow the operation he wanted to do for
the sinuses the press asked if the young
Roosevelt would make it home for the
holidays and Toby said he was dubious
then the injections began changing
Franklin juniors skin red this was still
the dye they were using by the way in
one side effect of this medicine was
that it turned people red it went away
after a while but their families were
concerned friend Toby told her that see
Toby told her that his skin would soon
return to its normal shade and then he
woke the patient to give more medicine
he woke the patient every hour took
blood samples and tracked his
temperature during the first long night
the
still little change but at least he
wasn't getting worse and then finally
FDR juniors fever began to subside toby
noticed that the swelling in his throat
was easing and by the middle of the day
the patient was sleeping more easily and
seemed to have more energy when he woke
the infected area in his cheek was no
longer as inflamed or tender his
temperature dropped to normal in the
space of a few hours and he woke up
hungry Toby told reporters that evening
that the patient was very much improved
so much so that an operation was no
longer needed in fact there was a
complete turnaround FDR jr. felt so much
better so quickly that Toby had to
enforce an unusual rule in order to
prevent damage to the healing throat
tissue he told the patient that he was
forbidden to laugh so that was that was
the difference twelve years made when
the news about FDR jr. hit the
newspapers
it caused a sort of a soulful mania in
the United States was 1936 and everybody
began asking for the medicine that had
cured the president's son and drug
companies quickly figured out that they
could make as much of it as they wanted
because it was unpatentable and it was
cheap to make so every drug company in
the United States started making sulfa
over the next ten years more than six
thousand patent applications were filed
for new sulfa drugs hundreds of
companies began manufacturing them and
at the time the drugs that they made
were made available over-the-counter to
anybody who wanted to buy them anybody
could buy sulfa drugs in their local
drugstore without a prescription because
the only things that were required to
have a prescription in 1936 were
narcotics everything else was available
over-the-counter why well because in
those days there were no powerful
medicines you know narcotics were the
only things they were known to be
addictive and narcotics were really the
only thing that people worried about
because nothing else really didn't you
think sofa sulfa however did do
something and everybody began taking it
somebody found out it could cure
gonorrhea and people began buying sulfa
and taking a few pills before they went
out for the
nurses one doctor remembered nurses
going around the hospital with sulfa in
their pockets and just sort of handing
it out to patients the joke at one
Medical Center was that you would come
into the Medical Center and they would
give you a week's worth of sulfa and
then they would do tests to see what you
had and that was the way that was the
way it was because no one had ever seen
a miracle like this nobody had ever seen
a medicine that worked and this worked
so well and with so few side effects
there are some but they're very mild
that that soon hundreds of thousands of
tons of this stuff were being
manufactured every year in the United
States of course it led to the other
shoe falling there was a tragedy
involved with a manufacturer who mixed
sulfa with diethylene glycol as a
solvent diethylene glycol is very
closely related to antifreeze but it was
the only thing that could dissolve sulfa
powder which it didn't dissolve well in
water it didn't dissolve well in alcohol
but man it dissolved really well in
diethylene glycol and this company the
massingill company in Bristol Tennessee
1937 sent out 200 gallons of a sweet
raspberry flavored they called it elixir
sulfanilamide specifically marketed at
children within a few months reports
started trickling in about deaths
starting in Tulsa Oklahoma there were
six children who died there and sort of
terrifically awful deaths and and then
across the nation the Food and Drug
Administration then a very small office
in the Department of Agriculture was
called in to try and corral what looked
like a disaster in the making and they
very quickly gathered up as much of this
tainted medicine as they could but
before it was all over a hundred and six
people had died around the country and
the public revulsion at this led to a
complete overhaul of the drug laws in
the United States the last major piece
of New Deal legislation that ever passed
by the Roosevelt administration just
before the war in nineteen
was a sweeping overhaul of the food and
drug laws of the United States that for
the first time required that a medicine
be proven safe and effective before it
goes to market prior to that anybody
could put a medicine on the market after
that we had a system very much like our
current system of drug laws and we owe
that to this horrible disaster that
happened with with sulfa the chemist by
the way who made that mistake the fella
who worked for the massingill company
who mixed up that batch of stuff denied
at first that he'd done anything wrong
and then started drinking diethylene
glycol to prove that it was non-toxic
and he didn't die from that but about
eight months after the disaster he shot
himself and killed himself
so you know there's two sides to every
medical discovery there you know we live
in an age when you know we're accustomed
to such great things happening with
medicines that often it's sometimes
difficult to remember that every great
discovery every boon that happens also
has its other side right every in fact
the the the Greeks two or three thousand
years ago the Greeks had a God of
healing who supposedly used as a magic
potion he is the blood of the Gorgon you
know Medusa was the Gorgon right and
Perseus cuts off Medusa's head and the
story that the Greeks told was that this
physician God used the Gorgons blood one
side the blood came from one side of the
Gorgon could raise the dead and cure
anything and the blood from the other
side was a certain poison so the Greeks
really understood that you don't get
away with all good stuff all the time
everything's a balance this tree of
sulfa as well the final chapter in the
story that I'll tell tonight is about
what happened to Gerhart domak the man
who found that drug he stayed in Germany
during World War two and worked under
under the Hitler government under the
Nazi government still trying to find new
medicines his next thing was to find a
cure for it to Burke
you'll OSIS and then a cure for cancer
he was working on those things
simultaneously really working himself to
death and then he found out in 1939 that
he'd won the Nobel Prize he was informed
by letter by the Nobel Committee and he
wrote them back and said gee this is
great and I'm happy to accept and then
the gestapo came and threw him in jail
because in germany at that time
german citizens were forbidden to accept
a nobel prize hitler had decided that no
good german would get a Nobel Prize
because because the Nobel Committee had
had made him angry a few years earlier
they awarded the Peace Prize to an
anti-nazi activist a fellow who was in a
concentration camp and it was clearly a
slap by the Nobel Committee at the
German government at the Nazi government
Hitler was so incensed he decreed no
German could accept a nobel prize well
the Germans didn't really take that too
seriously and they didn't win any Nobel
prizes for a few years until dome ox and
he said yes he was thrown in jail for
two weeks
and two other Germans who are awarded
Nobel prizes were brought into Gestapo
headquarters given letters to sign
refusing their prizes letters they were
told had been drafted by Hitler himself
democra fused a sign and he was released
after two weeks a physically broken man
but he was released a few weeks after
that he was on a train to go to a
meeting they pulled him off the train
they took him to another Gestapo
headquarters he finally signed his
letter and he didn't get his Nobel Prize
until after the war he then continued
his work searching for more cures and he
did find a cure for tuberculosis
although he never did for cancer
unfortunately so there are many other
stories in the book but I want to leave
it at that so that we have time for a
few questions if there are any if you do
have a question let me call on you and
then they're going to want to put a
microphone in front of you don't let
that intimidate you though I've been
talking at a microphone any questions at
all no I there's a question
Tom could you talk a little bit about
the research you did and some of the
challenges in that research thank you
I did research for this book for about a
year and a half and I I do know science
and I do write about science so the
science wasn't much of a challenge for
me per se I knew what molecules are and
and so on oh we're going to test it
let's do a test
let's see you let's see who knows who
knows a little chemistry here ok so an
atom walks into a bar and in F then Adam
walks into a bar looking very dejected
and goes up and sits at the bar and the
bartender says what's the matter and the
atom says I'm really dejected I've lost
an electron and the bartender says are
you sure and the atom says I'm positive
okay so anybody who didn't laugh doesn't
doesn't know where it could be the
people who groaned actually do know Kent
a lot of chemistry in any case I know a
little bit of science so I the challenge
for me was doing research in Germany
this story I like in retrospect
difficult to believe but no one had ever
written this story at length there were
references to it in a few places but I
was astounded as I went into it more
deeply how many ways this really created
what we call modern medicine today I had
to go to Germany to research things
there in the archives of the bear
company where Gomukh did his work I went
I spent a week there going through his
laboratory notebooks and and it was
possible for me to do that because they
had english-speaking staff because I
knew a minimum of German and because
laboratory notebooks are written in that
universal language that is science so
there were lots of pictures of molecules
which are you know fully translatable
they're sort of lingua franca and and
then there were a few abbreviations I
had to learn in his tests there are
hundreds and hundreds of pages these
failed tests as their searching for
these chemicals and the symbol for
failure in these tests was Oh W which
stands for ona velkommen it doesn't work
something like that yeah Owen iveco so
Oh W ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow out for
hundreds of pages and then when
something works it's W that's a dare :
and when in this seven hundred and
thirtieth chemical the one that was the
breakthrough DOMA took a red crayon and
wrote W with an exclamation so so in
some ways it was difficult in some ways
it was not it was actually great great
fun to do the researcher any other
questions
was there one back there yes had elapsed
between dough mocks discovery of sulfa
and the incident where the chemist had
thought to mix it with diethylene glycol
to dissolve it so I mean the way that it
was being used before almost sounds like
a recipe for disaster as
in terms of my giving the microbes the
chance to develop a resistance to it
that's a that's a great point
yeah antibiotic resistance is a is an
issue the today.i World Health
Organization listed among the top three
challenges facing healthcare in the 21st
century and eye antibiotic resistance
happens when you use a drug that an
antibiotic that kills bacteria in the
body there's there's a chance that some
of the bacteria that remain are
resistant to the effects of the drug and
what happens is if you take if you don't
do it right if you don't take your
antibiotic correctly what can happen is
that the antibiotic will kill all of the
susceptible bacteria but a few bacteria
that are resistant to the antibiotic
will live and they will repopulate and
you end up with a whole population of
bugs that don't that aren't killed by
the antibiotic that's called antibiotic
resistance sulfa drugs were not only
widely available and misused because no
one really knew how to use them at the
time but during the war there were also
a series of tests at army camps in u.s.
army Kam's army training camps
meningitis was an epidemic disease and
everyone was worried about it it kills
spinal disease caused it can be caused
by strep and there were tests done and
the army camps in which for long periods
of time
6,000 soldiers on this side of the camp
would get a sulfa pill every day with
every meal like three supper calls a day
and all the soldiers you know 6,000
soldiers on that side of the camp would
not and then they would compare the
groups and to their surprise after doing
this a few times they began to find that
the sulfus if at first it worked great
you know no meningitis on one side of
the camp meningitis on the other side of
the camp seemed to work terrific and
then after a couple of years it stopped
working it stopped in fact they had to
halt some of these tests because they
had created resistant strains of men of
strap that were causing meningitis there
were lessons that could have been
learned then you know this is 1942-43
there were lessons that could have been
learned then that would have
us a lot about stopping antibac or
stopping antibiotic resistance but those
lessons were not properly learned
because what happened at that point was
that penicillin came in right in the
middle of World War two penicillin came
in and everybody started using
penicillin and by now of course with the
new drug laws you had to get a doctor's
prescription theoretically to get
penicillin but still physicians were
exuberant because of the power of these
new medicines and began prescribed them
widely and now penicillin resistant
bacteria are common when I was at a
medical meeting I don't to scare anybody
maybe I shouldn't bring him but I was at
a medical meeting you should know the
and I and I talked about the book and
the physicians in the audience began
talking about mersa has anybody heard
about MRSA yes there's some health care
workers here Marissa is methicillin
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus I
think it's what it stands for
mrs a basically what it is is a bug
that's resistant to just about
everything just about everything because
there's the vancomycin resistant when it
is out there now so these doctors were
talking about creating these these
bacteria that are resistant not only to
a few antibiotics but to all antibiotics
well what do you do if you have a
bacteria like that what they're doing
now the physicians told me at this
meeting is that they're falling back on
sofa because sulfus been out of
circulation it's been a low use
antibiotic for so long that in some
cases when nothing else is working
they're going back to sulfa which is I
think it's an ironic point yes we have a
question up here
what led to like the penicillin came
about but why was that so much better
than sulfa and everyone forgot about
sulfa yeah
penicillin blew in you know in the world
scene in 1945 basically they figured out
during the war had a manufactured in
large quantities and the people who
figured it out
we're on the Allied side and the of the
conflict although the Germans tried to
make penicillin to their factories were
bombed before they could get there up
and rolling penicillin was another level
of wonder drug it was useful against
more kinds of bacteria every antibiotic
has a certain bacteria that it works
well on and certain bacteria that it
doesn't and sulfa for instance was
extremely good for streptococcus I which
caused a variety of disease a dozen
different diseases including scarlet
fever and some other very serious
diseases to a lesser extent for
meningococcal and Staphylococcus I other
related organisms responded very well to
sulfa but some other kinds of organisms
didn't respond at all well penicillin
had a wider sphere of action it was
better for more kinds of bacteria that
were dangerous and it seemed to have
very few side effects and they figured
out they were making so much of it
during the war they kept making it after
the war there is a point to that I
didn't really explore in the book and
I'm not certain of my facts 100% but I
believe that the drug companies that
made penicillin were in a patent
position that allowed them you know to
make a little more money on penicillin
than they would have on sulfone which
may have been a factor as well it is
true that in very short order sulfa
which was hailed around the world as a
miracle for about five years in the late
1930s before the war hit sulphate
disappeared just as rapidly as it
appeared was sort of a skyrocket you
know it went up it lit up the world for
a few years and it came down again but
those few years were vital and those
those fears I think really gifted us
with
with some wonderful wonderful medicines
as a last illustration I will mention
sulfus started to started going in the
mid 1930s so between the mid 1930s in
the mid 1950s a 20-year period with
penicillin showing up about halfway
through during that 20 year period the
mortality rate from childhood diseases
around the world dropped by 90% and
during that same 20 year period the
average lifespan in the United States
increased by 10 years this this the
impact of this drug and the drugs that
followed was so incredible the benefits
are so ingrained now in our society that
it's difficult to imagine that the good
times might end you know that if we're
not careful in the way that we use these
powerful drugs that we might end up with
a world in which bacteria figure out a
better system and and we are once again
as we were through history prey to
infections I hope that doesn't happen I
think that I think that we've learned a
lot
medically from this experience and I
think that the researchers that I've
talked to are coming up with newer and
better stuff all the time that's kind of
the system we've got and we've got it as
a result of sulfa any any last questions
all right I just want to say good night
thank you very much I'm here to sign
books if you'd like thank you